one of the most prized and overfished
bounties of the sea here bidders examine
tuna in a tokyo fish market
but better management of fishing means
things are actually looking up for four
tuna species that had been heading
towards extinction albacore yellowfin
and atlantic bluefin move from
endangered to least concern on the
iucn's red list southern bluefin moves
from critically endangered to endangered
that really is exciting news it shows
that
for marine species if we really are
work hard
and work with
within the legal frameworks work with
the fisheries industries we can achieve
sustainable harvesting and make fishery
a sustainable adventure that's the good
news but for other marine animals the
international union for the conservation
of nature is less optimistic it's
especially concerned for rays and sharks
overfishing habitat degradation and
climate change are taking a heavy toll
on many species there we find 37 percent
of them are threatened with extinction
and the primary
threat to sharks and rays is
exploitation overuse of the sharks on
land too humanity's impact on nature is
threatening the survival of new species
the iucn's red list update moves the
world's largest lizard komodo dragons
into the endangered category climate
change means much of their habitat on an
indonesian island could soon be
underwater
come on everybody
let's get to work
the iucn's world conservation congress
is underway in marseilles france actor
harrison ford brought some star power
it's hard
to read the headlines floods fires
famines
plagues and tell your children that
everything is alright
it's not all right and france's
president emmanuel macron appealed to
unity and human ingenuity
i would like for us to fight this battle
together and for my part i'm
extraordinarily confident the situation
is serious but our will is great the
capacity of the human species to
innovate is enormous
once more we're reminded that it is
humanity that's biodiversity's biggest
threat
rory challenge al jazeera